theoretically let's say that uh hunter
biden is getting money um because he can
just soak the cash up and they're
basically trying to bribe biden by
giving money to his son well you could
be an impeachable person and have
somebody try to bribe you by giving
money to your son but if they're sharing
bank accounts that means that that
firewall's gone joe biden could become
embroiled in the fbi's probe into
hunter's finances experts say emails
reveal they shared bank accounts paid
each other's bills and the president may
have even funded his son's 2018 drug and
prostitution binge now if if hunter
biden is getting money working for an
energy company which has no business and
he's sharing a bank account with his dad
and a prosecutor is investing in
investigating that company and then his
dad comes in and says fire him or i'm
going to
i'm going to withhold u.s allotted
funding that is so beyond criminal and
corrupt i am shocked that when donald
trump catches this on accident and has
no idea what it is and says what's going
on here they impeached him for it these
people are deeply deeply evil look at
this i mean come on man
when uh to quote joe biden how about
that come on come on man joe biden is in
photos with hunter and with hunter and
uh hunters associates and he lied and
said i didn't talk to my son about this
stuff no i'll tell you what it is
politico reported this a while back it's
called biden inc that the biden family
fortunes track alongside his political
career when joe biden was put in charge
of iraq under obama all of a sudden his
brother's getting these lucrative
contracts for construction in the
country now you have hunter biden
working at a company in which everyone
knows he has no business working yet no
expertise doesn't speak the language
sharing bank accounts joe biden comes in
gets the prosecutor who's investigating
the founder gets him fired threatening
to threatening to withhold funds from
the u.s government has no right to do
beyond abusive power and then what do
they do the media comes out and lies
they get trump impeached for it and now
here we are with many people in this
country still believing trump was the
one who was wrong for trying to get rid
of that corruption now truth be told i
don't think trump is a great detective
who was like i must do what's right and
save this country over this no i think
trump saw a meme video a meme that went
viral of joe biden saying son of a [ __ ]
guy got fired and trump's on the phone
he's like what was that video about
if you if you look at the transcript
it's very much trump bumbling into
something you have to ask yourself why
are so many high-ranking democrat family
members involved in ukraine ukrainians
energy companies i think it's because
the u.s policy on ukraine was that we
were it's not just ukraine at syria it's
the middle east the qatar turkey
pipeline was we are going to destroy
russia's ability to control natural gas
into europe because gas is too expensive
and we're going to do it by any means
necessary in 2009 it was it was reported
by the guardian i believe in 2012 that
in 2009 the u.s government had stated we
wanted to invade syria because bashar
al-assad was blocking our allies from
building a pipeline through syria and
turkey specifically because syria said
we are allies with russia and we won't
allow it then we ended up with our
adversaries i think it was iran are
saying they could tap the same gas field
and run it through iraq and into europe
and strengthen russia's gas monopoly so
the u.s has to do a few things they need
to control gazprom which runs through
ukraine and they need an alternative
source of fuel surprise surprise syria
falls in a civil war the u.s starts
funding the jihadis russia's pissed then
we start getting these these pro-western
you know protests now there's a there's
a lot of people saying it was a
cia-backed coup i'm not going that far
i'm saying the west of course is playing
their influence game the west doesn't
want to pay these prices for gas russia
doesn't want them to to screw around
with war and destroying their allies to
undercut their energy business
but more importantly if the u.s policy
on ukraine was to gain control to reduce
the cost of energy for our european
allies it appears that joe biden and
many other high profile individuals saw
that and said it's time to wet our beaks
a little on this one get our family
members in there so we can cut a profit
while it's all going down
what is fascinating about this what i'm
very much enjoying about this in
addition to learning a lot is
right now most of the debate happening
in foreign policy circles in the united
states is between realists which is what
i was talking about earlier power
billiard balls otto von bismarck that
kind of thing realists right and
liberals which in an ir context don't
think american liberals think
institution builders nato european union
wto right those are the two big fights
right now one of the other schools of
foreign policy that's not a big part of
the american experience at the moment
and don't freak out when i use this word
but it's marxist so marxist ir theory is
that it's not about power it's not about
institutions it's about money that that
you can look at international relations
and you can understand them by looking
at the ruling class of a country
enriching itself and this is fascinating
tim because i'm not trying to throw any
socialist aspersions at you i'm just
saying like your heuristic window is
more economically motivated so you've
got a very different interpretation of
this than most of the other news i've
been consuming lately and i find it very
interesting well i mean i i absolutely
look at the the ideological backing of a
lot of this too vladimir putin very much
wants to restore the might of the of the
former soviet empire he wants the the
russian empire back he wants that trade
union so very much he's looking at
countries like kazakhstan for instance
and he's saying how can i build up my
own block to compete with nato but but
uh ultimately it's i think a lot of
people have a simplistic view on things
you know i talk to my friends and i ask
them do you think vladimir putin is
intentionally trying to kill civilians
they'll say yes and i ask them why do
you think that is you know typically
people say it's because he's a bad guy
you know he wants to show the world how
powerful and scary is his evil and i'm
like isn't that a little naive you know
i certainly think vladimir putin is
killing civilians there's videos of it
and it's ridiculous to think that he
that he's not um but i don't think
vladimir putin gets up and says
i'm gonna kill civilians today i think
he's like this is a very strategic
target for us in kiev where ukrainian
forces are using it is a civilian target
hit it anyway i think it's it's more
nuanced it's things like that i think
any time you hear people going he's mad
that's lazy
right like it's possible but very
unlikely generally speaking when when
somebody who's previously made rational
if immoral unethical decisions which
they're not the same thing you can be
rational and unethical allah darth vader
um when somebody has a track record of
doing that you're like i don't
understand what he's doing he's probably
crazy that means that your heuristics
are probably off and you need to
reassess what their motivations are yeah
it's a complicated uh uh
world we live in it's it's not just oil
yeah you don't think geopolitics is just
black hats versus white hats all the
time although that's all i think it's
more nuanced than that the us government
can do no wrong they've never lied to us
a great example of that tim is the fact
that we only make allies based on
liberal democracy that's why we're such
good friends with saudi arabia you know
that republican democratic government
with a haiki and open market and
individual rights and we're very
anti-fascist which is of course why
we're absolutely opposed to the nazis
and the azov battalion yeah and
mercenaries like we wouldn't hire like
black water you know a bunch of dirty
work in the middle east or anything
here's what i tell people i i certainly
think that for the elites in this
country they view cultural issues as
somewhat secondary like i don't think
nancy pelosi knows or cares all that
much about what gen z thinks culturally
i think a lot of it is how can you
control systems
but you know i i think
you know what i tell people is
when it came to hillary clinton and
donald trump
i would tell my friends do you like it
that you know you can work
in new york at a media company where you
write articles about brad pitt's junk
and get paid 65 000 a year like are you
happy with the amount of money you make
in the job you have and they typically
are like well you know i probably should
make more and something like okay would
you prefer it if you had to i don't know
shovel coal for five dollars an hour
would that be a better life for you and
they're like what no of course not i
said okay let me explain to you why you
get to work in new york city
why you get paid 65 000 a year to write
articles once a week about brad pitt's
junk doesn't that seem a little wrong to
you like something's wrong with this
system where you basically do nothing of
value but you're making what is that
seven or eight times what people in
mexico or brazil make isn't that strange
yeah it's because of the petro dollar
it's because of us
the war machine it's because the united
states it's it's special interest groups
are willing to destroy countries to get
cheap fuel and cheap energy
and the petro dollar helps
helps us very much so in that we don't
need to rely on exports for a strong
currency we just point guns at people
and say you better use ours again this
is interesting because this is marxist
ir theory like marxist ir theory there's
a subset of called world systems theory
and the idea in world systems theory is
that there's an industrialized core of
capitalist countries there's a semi
periphery of cheap labor and there's a
periphery of subsistence level resource
extraction and if if you're going with
world systems theory then like you look
at vietnam and you're like well vietnam
was about
annexing or maintaining vietnam as part
of the american economic supply chain it
didn't have to do with containment
theory right
and like you're how you're interpreting
this would fall in line with that yeah
yeah no i'm not surprised i mean there's
a reason why
i went down occupy wall street was
interested in it i think class-based
issues are substantially more important
than race or or identity based issues
one of the problems we have right now in
the country
is that the left has adopted uh
critical race theory which
it pits
people uh regular people against each
other poor people against each other you
end up with people like serena williams
who is one of the wealthiest people on
the planet most famous and and most uh
um
celebrated and she's a victim and she's
oppressed and you'll get a homeless
white veteran who is an oppressor now
that system clearly does not make sense
class issues
matter substantially more than uh these
you know ridiculous ideas about
privilege now i certainly think racism
exists right i think the problem with
the left is they they're
they see things too much at the surface
level
white privilege is not what it is it's
majority privilege you know in any
country in which you're the majority
you're going to have some benefits
because people think look and act like
you more so than other people immigrants
or strangers but they just say it's
white privilege which is extremely
reductive when you have someone who's
white from south africa or a white
person from ukraine uh from from ukraine
luke rudkowski comes on who's on the
show every so often
he's a blond-haired blue-eyed polish guy
but according to the critical race
theorists he's a person of color
absolutely this is why the the coalition
of communities of color say that slavic
people are people of color even if
they're white with blonde hair and blue
eyes no joke i'm english scottish
clydesdale i think the 23andme test was
off oh then you're you're you're like
you're watching i'm straight up i'm just
a jar of mayonnaise i feel like you can
reverse engineer critical race theory to
look at it as critical theory to see the
class structure ripped away because what
happened is when slavery ended in the
united states a bunch of people were
just
descendants of slaves and slaves were
jumped on the streets with no education
no money so their kids had no education
no money most of them then their kids
tend to have low or little education of
money and so we're looking at like the
seventh generation now of a lot of those
families irrelevant of the skin color
they just happened to in this iteration
of slavery you come from that area
redlining go on as well so which would
be the best way to accumulate
multi-generational wealth is home
ownership and that was basically
precluded up until 30 years ago 40 years
ago so now and you could argue there is
systemic racism in this but that it is a
class system yes but the economic
fallout is the main factor also
to introduce more complexity to what
we're talking about here it wasn't
necessarily just a straight line of this
group of people not gaining wealth
through the generations it's actually
the case that prior to the 1960s there
were fewer black out of wedlock births
than there are today by a significant
margin and we know one of the best ways
to prevent poverty is to ensure that
you're married before you have children
and so
there are things that were done to the
black community some say the war on
drugs some say they were on poverty the
brookings institute has actually said
legal abortion is a big part of it but
there are policies that came much later
yeah i i think there are i so i i think
systematic racism is
is it absolutely exists but there's
there's an issue of
how the left interprets it what they
think it means and how far and extreme
they go with it so i'll give you an
example you'll talk to one of these
critical race theorists about systemic
racism and they'll tell you today
you know that all police are racist or
whatever and i'm like okay you got to
stop you got to stop right the average
person is substantially less racist
leaning towards not even racist for the
most part these days that's the average
person you know but but but they'll tell
you the whole system is racist what the
way i explain to people is that in the
united in chicago easiest example we had
two big problems block busting and
redlining have you ever heard of these
redlining of course is very famous it's
where you have the red line trains these
the real estate companies would isolate
certain areas where they would only sell
to black people and they wouldn't sell
outside creating these you know
segregated areas blockbusting is one of
the dirtiest and most evil things you
know i've ever heard about it's where
these companies would go to a white
neighborhood
buy a house move a black family in and
then go door to door to all the houses
and say there goes the neighborhood you
better sell to us before it's too late
the people would panic sell at a premium
to the to these companies who would then
kick the black family out and sell the
whole neighborhood back to white people
at for a profit that was made illegal
redlining was made illegal but only in
the 80s that means there are people my
age today who are just now the first
generation getting out of overtly
nowadays illegal systems that caused
damage to people based on their race
so what i could say is yes obviously
today remnants of that racism still
exists in the system are individuals
racist some still are but for the most
part we've done a lot to change that the
solution however is not to go to a poor
white person and say you will not be
granted access to this we will take
money from you that makes no sense now
that we've changed the laws the solution
is class based because if the left
believes that the black community is
disproportionately impoverished then
class-based issues will still
disproportionately favor them but it
won't leave behind latinos asians or
white people who are also negatively
impacted i i have an ex-girlfriend who
uh when we were dating her father lived
um i won't say where it is it's not out
her but uh her father if she wanted to
call him she couldn't because he didn't
own a phone
she was white by the way so was her
father um but like if she wanted to get
in contact with her dad she'd call her
neighbor and have her neighbor walk over
to get her dad because her dad was that
poor and i think that's a good example
of like i don't really feel like saying
yet massive privilege really counts like
like that that guy that couldn't afford
a phone i feel like is is economically
underprivileged and i'll give you
another example of um
systemic racism at work in government
that's still there when you look at
almost all zoning laws uh i am most
familiar with los angeles uh to plug it
i wrote a book called los angeles it's
hideous palms about an ugly city so if
you don't like la and you like funny
stuff it's a funny part i'll i'll get
your copy timothy that sounds good it's
it's fun i don't like l.a yeah i don't
know it's it's just an asphalt carbuncle
uh but in the process of researching
these poems that i wrote about los
angeles um the reason that los angeles
is the massive sprawling city that it is
is not uh it is accidental but it's not
unavoidable the reason that it's so
sprawling is that los angeles during the
i guess would be the the 40s and 50s uh
basically like many cities in america
but i'm most familiar with that like
when uh oh no black people are moving in
we should basically outlaw apartment
buildings because the the it was racist
it was overtly racist at the time and
the thinking was well if we make people
live in homes and houses white people
can afford houses more than black people
can so already there's going to be an
advantage there but the way law is set
up in california is that houses uh in
certain neighborhoods have what are
called neighborhood covenants where you
own the property but if you have to sell
it the neighborhood itself has to write
off on that they have to sign off on
that meaning that you have to be a
morally upstanding person of irish kind
of color right and so that was
intentional so you look at like los
angeles today 80 of the real estate in
los angeles now
you can't have more than one family
living in a place you have to have a
house
even though it's like what the second
bigger is the biggest city in america
you can't build up legally you can't
build up you have to build out so it's
pancaking do you know the story of saint
louis
so st louis isn't actually one city it's
uh i think it's a 99 plus smaller
jurisdictions all cluttered together
really st louis is a city don't get me
wrong but to the greater saint louis
area that people refer to is actually a
collection of a whole bunch of small
cities and so uh what happened here was
a long long time ago in st louis that we
we ended up with for a variety of
reasons desegregation comes into play
and there were many white people uh and
you got you got to understand that back
in the in the late 50s and 60s this
country was what like 92 nine or
whatever percent white
so you have you have these white
communities overtly white start seeing
black families moving into certain areas
and so they decide to start leaving
what they did was they moved outside of
the city and created their own
communities with covenant with with you
know covenants like
you're only allowed to have 10 houses in
this city can't build any more to make
sure no one else could move in
long story short by today we have 90
plus jurisdictions each with their own
police department what ends up happening
is that many of these areas that are
impoverished and there is a tie between
the black community and historical
poverty for a variety of reasons like
blockbusting redline blockbusting and
redlining and we know that homeownership
is one of the ways that people transfer
wealth making it very difficult for them
what happens is this system that is not
i wouldn't call uh uh
today i wouldn't say it is racist but it
was created through
racist ideas people what we would call
systemic racism right like it's a great
example of like
those of us with more like libertarian
inclinations can go great i don't like
regulations and this is a great example
of regulations being racist that we also
unite out and root them out so what ends
up happening is for racial reasons we
end up with all these jurisdictions
today and so i went down
i was in ferguson during the michael
brown writes and uh i worked in a
documentary i produced a documentary
about what was going on there's
something they have called going on tour
so what happens is you are uh in one of
these neighborhoods that is
predominantly black
you your your lower income for a variety
of reasons you have a vehicle and uh
your plate is expired now it's 20 bucks
to to get your plate registered
but you're poor
you've got
you know debt you've got credit cards so
you decide do i eat do i pay gas or do i
get my plate fixed you say well look i
got to eat i got to pay my rent i can
hope i don't get pulled over from my
plate
you drive from you so in order to go to
work you're likely going to drive
through two or three different cities
because they're these small
jurisdictions we saw this with a ton of
people they would leave their
neighborhood and while they're driving
they get pulled over and the cop says
your plate's expired here's your ticket
have a nice day they start driving again
they get pulled over 10 minutes later
plates expire jurisdiction in a
different jurisdiction and it keeps
happening then finally when they're like
i couldn't pay the 20 bucks i can't pay
the hundred
what happens is they'll get arrested and
it'll be like a two day thing you
couldn't pay the fine it's two days in
jail yeah what happens when they get out
of jail the police from the next
jurisdiction are waiting for them to
take them to the next jail and they
might have lost their job during that
time and they and they usually did now a
lot of people say well they shouldn't be
driving with expired plates
perhaps that's true for a lot of these
people it's like yo i have to drive to
get to work i live in the suburbs but
another issue we we saw was people who
would get uh tickets for their their
headlight going out and so you're doing
your driving you don't even know your
headlights out you get pulled over this
is one of the stories we heard and the
guy's like so i say okay i'll go home i
gotta drive through two or three more
cities where i get pulled over and end
up with four tickets all for this
to the people that say like they
shouldn't be driving with expired plates
why do we have those like i get having a
serial number on your car that
identifies you own it makes sense to me
you should have that right but the
little tags that's just a regressive tax
that all that that's all that is it
doesn't do anything it's like the reason
we do that is because poor people are
the easiest group of taxpayers to
militate against it's lot heart like try
doing a tax on yoga and see what happens
to you you're not going to get a bunch
of upper middle class white people let
you do that thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 p.m and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you